this video is brought to you by skill
share an online learning community for
creators with tens of thousands of
classes in design business and more if
you click below you will get a two-month
trial for free preview membership with
skill share gives you unlimited access
to that platform so you can join the
classes and communities that are just
right for you whether you want to fuel
your curiosity creativity or even your
career skill share is the perfect place
to keep you learning and thriving I
recently taken a course on better email
management my inbox was getting pretty
out of control and as in really nice
attack alert so I went on Skillshare I
found something to sort me out and now
I've got an actual system in place for
dealing with emails rather than just
having the train wreck that I had
previously that course is called email
productivity works smarter with your
inbox it's by someone called Alexandre
Samuel and I recommend checking it out
so yes Skillshare just go do it you can
get two months for free and after that
it's just $10 a month which is
incredibly affordable especially when
compared to pricey in-person courses and
workshops Sport visual politik by
supporting Skillshare that would be
great link below and let's get into it
[Applause]
[Music]
dear viewers in this video we're going
to talk about a very special
relationship so special that it's close
to reaching its 70th anniversary yes
love has finally come to visual politic
but hold on a second do you think we're
just talking about two ordinary lovers
though not at all a protagonist love
each other and they also hate each other
they need each other they also despise
each other I'm talking about the
connection between Argentina and the
International Monetary Fund fondo
monetary or international so the origin
points promise themselves over and over
again that they won't go back to the IMF
but then just a few years later the
relationship picks up again where it
left off frente Tanoa situatio de Manila
prevent IVA a decision easier
conversation al fondo monetary
international to give you an idea since
the mid-1950s Argentina has had to
negotiate an IMF rescue package roughly
every four and a half years so why on
earth does Argentina keep having this
recurring dependence on the IMF whose
fault is it can this relationship ever
be finalized well let's investigate but
first we need to know how it all began
[Music]
the origin of a toxic love in 1946 the
International Monetary Fund emerged as
an offshoot of the Bretton Woods
agreements of 1944 back then world war
ii had just ended europe was shattered
and the Western Allies were preparing to
face economic consequences and the
demands of reconstruction at that time
the idea in everyone's minds was to
avoid what had happened after World War
one that is to accelerate recovery and
avoid the emergence of crises that could
tip some countries towards radical
movements or even nudge them into the
Soviet orbit with that in mind and with
the Marshall Plan three institutions
emerged from Bretton Woods to achieve
this goal these institutions are still
with us today first the IMF or
International Monetary Fund's would act
as a last resort lender for countries
with strong fiscal imbalances or
currency crises in other words the IMF
would provide the necessary resources so
that these countries could develop
reforms with which to correct their
imbalances secondly what we know of
today as the World Bank was created as
in order to be in charge of offering
loans with low interest rates and long
loan repayment periods to help countries
finance their reconstruction and
encourage large investment projects the
third one was gas the general agreement
on tariffs and trade the prelude to what
is now the World Trade Organization
which was born precisely to promote free
trade
thus favored economic growth
although it may be hard to believe today
at that time Argentina had some of the
best economic conditions on the planet
which is why it was invited to be a
founding member of the IMF from the
outset however hon Domingo perón who had
just been elected presidents of
Argentina was not the man for the job
let's just say that he had a very
different model in mind for Argentina
one which had nothing to do with this
kind of large-scale economic integration
by the way I'll leave a link in the
description to a video all about Juan
Domingo perón and the changes he made in
Argentina so you can check that out
however things soon changed in 1955
Peron was overthrown by a military coup
d'etat by then the country's economic
situation was already quite different
they at high inflation rates high public
deficits and no foreign exchange
reserves all of this led to factor
president Pedro agencia our Amuro to
join the IMF and request aid of almost 1
billion dollars in today's money
and with that the romance had begun and
around the same time Argentina had
already started to look more like the
Argentine we know today but hold on a
second some of you might be wondering
well how how does it work does the IMF
just give money like that do you ask for
a loan with more favorable conditions
and it's just done and dusted is it an
NGO perhaps something like that well no
not exactly
you see the IMF grants financing with
very favorable conditions but also
imposes conditions that it sees as
necessary to correct the problems in
order to eventually recover the money
that was granted of course no country is
obliged to ask for or accept their help
in fact some countries have refused to
work with this agency in the past but if
you do accept their money and conditions
then you have to fulfill said conditions
right
well the truth is that in argentina's
case the broken promises came pretty
quick same old story
when'll torah from DZ took over as
president in 1958 just two years after
Argentina's first bailout the country
again asked the IMF for help on that
occasion the I lapse condition was that
in exchange for receiving the money
Argentina would have to push through a
significant cut in public spending and
eliminate import price controls and
restrictions then once they received the
money well let's just say the adjustment
plan was never fulfilled in fact the
following governments that of Arturo
Umberto Elia decided to distance itself
completely from the funds
recommendations and of course things did
not improve quite the opposite in fact
after another military coup in 1966 on
this occasion at by hon Carlos on ganya
the country once again fell into the
hands of the IMF this time the
international organizations conditions
were harsh and yet the Argentine
government still never corrected its
imbalances so much so that between 1966
and 1973 the Argentine external debt
grew by 50% or up to four point eight
billion which would be almost the
equivalent of 30 billion dollars today
as you can see the events don't differ
much from what we've seen in Argentina
in recent years but this was still just
the beginning of the romance
[Applause]
you're not sure when I really love out
of beat pika another time for a lot of
big in three years later in 1975 there
was another military coup this time led
by General Jorge Rafael Videla at the
time the economy was once again broken
down to give you an idea the country was
coming from an economic crisis that
resulted in the so called road ragazzo a
brutal devaluation of the currency by a
hundred percent on the dollar which not
only caused huge inflation but also a
shortage of many types of products and
given those circumstances what do you
think the new military government did by
exactly they ran straight back to the
arms of the IMF in fact videos
governments maintained very close
relations with this organization and a
large torrent of money flowed into
Argentina from the fund and yes we
already told you before on visual
politics during that time Washington saw
any dictatorships that didn't commune
with the Soviet bloc in a positive light
no matter how criminal it was surely
that influenced the huge amount of money
that the IMF poured into Argentina the
surprising fact is that vidhya's
government actually did manage to meet
the imf's requirements regarding
economic stabilization what they didn't
manage to do was cut public spending
which is why fiscal imbalances and the
demand for funds continued
by the way in a future video here on
visual politic we're going to talk long
and hard about the policies that the IMF
and the fund itself promulgated and know
the IMF isn't an NGO not at all it is a
lender that lends under favorable
conditions but it's also a lender that
intends to recover its money during the
dictatorship and just seven years
Argentina's external debt multiplied by
six reaching the astounding figure of
forty two billion dollars at the time it
was obvious that the country was broke
and to top it off this period under
military rule ended with the Falcons
disaster this happens just when they
thought things couldn't get any worse
often that last blow that was returned
to democracy when Ralph Olson came to
power on December the 10th 1983
democracy came with many expectations
its democracy you eat heal and educate
yourself are foreseen unfortunately even
this straightforward prophecy was never
fulfilled but let's stay on track after
reaching power alphonse and rejected the
fund even announcing an audit on the
debt that the military government had
contracted a gesture of sovereignty can
you guess what happens two years later
in 1985 under a colossal mountain of
debt and rising inflation they are
forcing government once again and asked
the fund for help you know how it goes I
love you I love you not and so on and so
on such a sweet story
once again the INF set conditions but
once again the promises remained just
promises that is how offenses mandate
ended in a complete disaster with a
runaway crisis and rising hyperinflation
to give you an idea in 1989 inflation
was over 2000 percent
[Music]
[Applause]
and then came a brand-new President
Carlos Menem and with him came more help
from the IMF the Brady plan a plan that
forced Argentina to restructure its
external debt privatize the Social
Security system privatized public
companies eliminate taxes on financial
transactions and create a new currency
tied to the dollar to avoid the
country's endemic inflation many things
were done during my name's time
especially during his first term and
what's more I actually worked but he
still didn't do the most difficult thing
of all
he didn't adjust public spending in
facts he did quite the contrary under
this president's mandate public spending
continued to grow and with it the
government's external desk check this
out that is how men ins presidency ended
with another huge crisis that paved the
way for the famous default of December
2001 just months after the IMF granted
the government of Menem successor
fernando de la rúa a mega rescue package
of 40 billion dollars known as a
financial armoring there was the
definitive default of 2001 the AMA had
lasted only ten months
and after that came a new crisis that
pushed poverty in Argentina to above 50%
of the population as you can see every
IMF bailout has ended in a resounding
failure and it's become normal
the IMF can give a lifeline to a country
so long as it balances its accounts but
even if it doesn't the result will
always be the same and in Argentina many
things have been done except for really
opening up the economy and cutting
public spending there's also the issue
of the size of the state which is
absolutely gigantic once an example well
check out this graph that we've shown
you on previous occasions it's truly
truly scary and do not think that this
has been a good deal for the IMF not at
all Argentina has been an example of
this organizations incapacity it has
been a source of constant humiliation
because Argentine politicians accepted
the money but never corrected the
problems and so with such a mess and
this a lack of reliability nothing was
working
nothing could work but then what happens
with koechner ISM they never sought
funding from the IMF so why did the
president
the Kerch nurse the coach nurse didn't
ask the IMF for help that's true but
their story does of a catch you see
after the 2001 default Argentina never
paid most of its nominal debt which led
to a restructuring that eased the
pressure on public accounts to this we
need to add that during most of
Kirchner's years the price of soybeans
and natural resources which the country
exports were sky-high that means a huge
influx of dollars so the current
government had some wiggle room to
continue expanding public spending
without having to resort to the IMF the
problem was that those conditions didn't
last when the price of soybeans and
other raw materials fell the usual
government problems returned as well as
price controls exchange controls and
restrictions of all times that was
precisely what led Macri to the Casa
Rosada
but with Macri things didn't change
either public spending continued to
skyrocket and the promise of gradual
change was so gradual that most of the
reforms simply never came the oxygen ran
out and with it the Argentine economies
autonomy so in May 2018 the government
requested a new rescue package from the
IMF in this case it amounted to more
than 50 billion dollars
and so the cycle starts again the IMF
sets conditions and Argentine
politicians don't want to comply with
them crisis grows so politicians use the
IMF as a scapegoat
then they reject the international body
and the hatred stage begins and finally
they go running back into its arms it's
a neverending story since the 50s
Argentina has requested a rescue from
the IMF roughly every four and a half
years and none of the rescues have ever
worked isn't it time maybe for a change
isn't it time for Argentine politicians
to understand that the country needs
this change isn't it time for the IMF to
understand that it has never really
helped Argentina because it has dragged
out a scenario that is just leading the
country from bad to worse so what do you
think well leave your answer in the
comments below and I really hope you
enjoyed this video do you hit that like
button if you did don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos also
please do check out our friends at the
reconsider media podcast who provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine also this channel is possible
because of patreon and our patrons on
that platform please do consider joining
them and supporting our mission of
providing independent political coverage
and as always I'll see you next video
[Music]